frontier markets they're on the brink of
becoming emerging markets but they can
also be on the brink of slipping down
into a more chaotic environment during
my years of writing about emerging
markets there's one question that's come
out quite a lot which is what should I
invest in I've just written this book
the journey took me through ten
countries in the space of six months it
was a journey across four continents I
started by researching the
best-performing emerging market fund
managers and I asked them which country
do you favor the most for the next five
to ten years and can I come along there
with you Kenya is absolutely beautiful
we went to the Safari because tourism is
such a big deal for Kenya it's got one
of the most successful technology
companies in Safaricom this is a company
that basically created mobile money
it's got fairly good regulation and then
as a growing economy the consumer sector
is very very important Kenya as part of
the global picture of countries that are
fighting Islamic terrorism only did it
have a huge attack by al-shabaab the
President and the Vice President were
being charged by the International
Criminal Court for crimes against
humanity
for Saudi Arabia it's a very advanced
economy and that's all around you from
the buildings to the roads but the
infrastructure often doesn't work
the really big opportunity is the Saudi
stock market opening to the public which
should be later in 2015 what you're
seeing now from Saudi Arabia is a real
push to get people working there's huge
inequality the most surprising things
was in the centre of Reard visiting a
slum there is enormous repression I came
out of a museum and I was face to face
with a crowd watching a man beheaded
Argentina is very very unusual in that
is one of the few emerging markets
that's actually been downgraded to run
tamaki elections they're expected later
this year we'll change everything
Argentina has done so many things wrong
during the last few years that even if
you have half sensible policies from new
government there's going to be a massive
improvement natural resources are
important as well even in this climate
of collapsing oil prices frontier
markets frontier markets because there's
a dangerous element behind them in the
case of Argentina it's certainly because
you don't know which way this government
is going to swing next i went to vietnam
with mark mobius who is considered the
grandfather of emerging markets what
vietnam has going for it is a very
dynamic population i mean the people are
very resourceful it's a big consumer
population there's consumption going on
everywhere Viet Nam's biggest challenge
at the moment is China the Chinese
situation has the potential to make
Vietnam kind of a pawn and the danger is
that if it gets caught up in all that
then it can affect trade relations
Nigeria will be the third biggest nation
on the planet by 2050 you have a country
that's going to become hugely
geopolitically importance we talked to
the finance minister there and she was
less interested in talking to us about
oil and more interested in other
industries like Nollywood it makes more
films than Hollywood more films than
Bollywood Nigeria's challenges are huge
right now Nigeria is the market that has
the biggest losses so far this year
number one oil prices collapsing
Nigeria's wealth is very very unequal
sushi Dream Li divided between the north
and the south and that's the roots of
the tensions that we see now with Boko
Haram to the elections creating
uncertainty in tensions particularly
because they've been delayed putting all
that together you see a country where
there's very little reason to go in
right now the point is after the
elections what this country looks like
forward